hey chess is back and we're going back
in time for a deep dive into the latest
trailer I don't know about you guys but
I'm really pumped for this season and
it's 80s slash slasher vibes now I've
left a link to the trailer below so if
you haven't seen it give it a look then
come on back now let's get into it
we start off with this exterior shot of
a cabin at Camp redwood the main setting
for season 9 but as I'll get into later
this season like previous seasons will
include flashbacks and time jumps in
this next shot of two women cuddling up
together
notice the graininess of the film almost
like it's supposed to be shot in the
style of a 70s or 80s slasher contrast
that to this where we're introduced to
our main cast and the graininess is gone
if you've been watching the teasers FX
has released over the last few months
they all include this type of graininess
and none of them feature they main cast
so the teasers were likely a means to
show the original massacre which will
likely see more of via flashbacks
throughout the season as we'll find out
later by a character named Breda this is
the site of the worst summer Massacre of
all yeah this intro scene is depicting
that massacre a massacre at the hands of
a character we'll come to know as mr.
jingles cuddle time is cut short with
his arrival we get a better look at the
inside of the cabin and several sleeping
campers here's mr. jingles keyring that
jingle when he walks hence his name
we've seen mr. jingles in the cast
teaser video here played by John Carroll
Lynch who in previous age s seasons
played John Wayne Gacy and twisty the
clown notice the blood splatter on the
sheets here inferring that he's already
killed a few campers as well as his
weapon of choice a knife although not
quite a machete like Jason Voorhees this
poor remaining victim is the girl we saw
in the first shot with the sunflower
earring and judging by this last shot it
doesn't look like she's made it out
alive
I however wouldn't count it out that
there will be a survivor of this
original massacre since it's a common
horror trope to have someone from the
past come back and retell the experience
to our host of newcomers and it looks
like we'll get that in Leslie Grossman's
character who we see here she's also
seen in the cast teaser wearing a
nightgown and will later see her as some
sort of head counselor when the gang
arrives
camp she is likely the lone survivor of
this massacre who for some reason or
another has decided to stay and work at
the camp
slashers are known for having surprised
killers so if I were to bet on anyone it
would be her we get a shot of the new
ahs 1984 logo which is totally in line
with the slasher theme and speaking of
newcomers here we are in 1984 at an
aerobics class with our favorite son of
Satan leading the class currently we
only know two of the main casts names
Emma Roberts who plays Brooke and
Angelica Ross who plays Rita in class we
get a look at Billie Lords rocker s
character and this built humpin man yet
unnamed but portrayed by actor Gus
Kenworthy another shot of Emma Roberts
and I'm pretty sure this is gonna get
demonetized
but take a look at who she has her eyes
on our pal Gus over here who makes sure
to show a little skin at the perfect-10
aerobics class Cody fern tells the gang
that he got a job at a summer camp that
they're opening up a couple of hours
from here and suggests they all join him
we also get a shot of another one of the
main characters over here portrayed by
Darren Horton notice also the LA 1984
poster in the background which pretty
much confirms that we are indeed in 1984
here is where things get a little more
complicated we see this hand trying to
open a screen door and the next shot is
at Brooks la home where she's sleeping
soundly this is followed by a man who I
believe is not mr. jingles cutting
through the screen door with a curved
knife we know mr. jingles uses a
straight knife the intruder is about to
kill Brooke until we cut partner pardon
the pun as we find out later on from
Cody ferns character Brooke had a
real-life experience with a slasher so
she likely survive this ordeal and will
now have to relive this trauma and
overcome it this season my guess as to
who her assailant is might be this guy
from the cast teaser video
he's long black hair and oh yeah it's
probably him here we get an aerial shot
of the gang in a van the greenish van
and homage to the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre and here we see Brooke
hesitantly taking a flask of booze
leading me to believe her character will
be closely in line with the virgin
stereotype commonly attributed to scream
queens in eighties slasher films now
this may be me looking too hard into
things but the fact Billie Lord's
character has her arm around Brooke and
previously mentioned
that it's about time there was more
estrogen in the group leads me to
believe she might be gay for Brooke
since we know AHS isn't shy of
representing LGBTQ characters the van
hits an unknown individual now they want
us to believe it could be mr. jingles
but this shot here shows it's someone
with longer hair in a beige top and mr.
jingles is bald the van rushes to Camp
redwood where they have taken the man
they hit to see the camp nurse nurse
Rita they lie saying they found him on
the road when they're interrupted by
KOCO st. Pierre Vanderbilt oh no that's
just Leslie Grossman's yet-to-be-named
character who seems to be some sort of
head counselor or a coordinator in
charge of showing the new counselors
around remember we saw the younger
version of her character in that opening
scene we're also introduced to chef
birdy who's been around the camp for
years so even though she says she has
nothing but fond memories here it's
likely she'll have some horror stories
to tell as well like these brief flashes
of the girl we saw from the beginning
being dragged away by mr. jingles
the counselors help take boxes of eggs
so on the right here we just get a
glimpse of the cafeteria where there
will likely be a lot of scenes and
here's one of my favorite scenes from
the teaser because it's an outright
homage to John Carpenter's Halloween
with a patient from the local
psychiatric hospital having escaped just
like Michael Myers mr. jingles has
escaped and found a knife so he can
continue his hunt around the campfire
they discuss what Kody calls a ghost
story about mr. jingles
even though Rita claims that it actually
happened this is followed by a slew of
quick shots which ramp up the action we
have mr. jingles crashing through a
cabin window and hurling what appears to
be a flaming brick with Billy Lords
reaction but I think that was just
placed in there by the editing there's
this shot of Brooke here where she seems
frozen by the hook knife slasher now I'm
not sure if these shots are real or in
Brookes mind as I stated earlier I think
she's going to be traumatized by her
assault but it remains to be seen
whether it's in her head
or if a little manifest somehow in real
life but my guess is that it could be a
combination of both as seen in the shot
here of the hook knife man watching over
another counselor heading into a cabin
Billy in the water here and judging by
her look she is not alone now her hair
isn't wet here which leads me to believe
that she didn't run into the water to
escape something rather that something
is following her while she is bathing
quick shot
here for peeping tom you can kind of see
the naked leg of what I think is a man
here taking a shower now there are only
three main cast members that have been
announced to have blue eyes that's Cody
fern Gus Kenworthy and Matthew Morrison
and knowing that Gus's character is in
two women we can probably narrow this
down to Cody or Matthew here let me know
what you think in the comments below
here's a shot of mr. jingles clenching
his fists next to his ring of keys this
is followed by a grainy shot of jingles
holding a tire iron about to hit up line
folded man the graininess suggesting
this is a flashback from the original
massacre a terrified Rita here as what
appears to be a tree log is thrown
through one of the cabin windows and I
love this shot here a brook covered in
dirt shocked at what she's seeing this
is followed by mr. jingles looking like
he's stumbling away he's not even
holding a weapon here and I have a super
odd feeling that mr. jingles isn't who
we think he is
here's Doron horns character also
covered in dirt like Brooks's character
likely trying to make a getaway in that
car there but if we've learned anything
from slasher films the car wires have
been cut or the battery's dead Rita's
here asking for help covered in blood we
know that probably won't turn out well
but my guess is the woman she's asking
for help from is this woman we see her
briefly earlier on in the trailer
investigating the breakout at this
psychiatric hospital if I were to take a
guess Rita gets saved by her only for
both of them to get captured by mr.
jingles seen here in the background here
we have mr. jingles banging on the camp
door as Billy and another counselor we
haven't been introduced to yet pull back
what appears to be an injured Cody and
what slasher movie wouldn't have a
creepy gas station attendant saying
you're all going to die this dude's name
is probably Roy as evidenced by the sign
in the background and also check out the
license plate van to see like fantasy I
swear this better not all be a dream the
trailer ends there but it leaves many
unanswered questions chiefly among them
how are they going to fill an entire
season about just one Massacre if you
look at almost all the shots in the
trailer the cast are wearing these same
exact clothes leading me to believe that
what we've seen so far takes place over
one night how is it possible over ten
episodes unless the season doesn't take
place entirely at Camp redwood perhaps
Camp redwood is only the beginning
and it branches off further or some of
the survivors return years later we know
that HS will frequently kill off
characters only to bring back the actors
and have them portray someone else we
also haven't seen any signs of Sarah
Paulsen who has been confirmed as a
guest role for this season but not main
cast HS seasons in the past have seen a
slew of horrific killers creatures
ghosts and monsters yet this trailer
only has two mr. jingles and the hook
knife man both of whom are pretty
generic slasher characters who we've
seen before HS will really need to give
us something new and fresh if they're
gonna keep us interested now I'm gonna
say this but I could be totally wrong
but I also think that they may be faking
us out and mr. jingles might actually be
a good character who was framed for
their original camp redwood murders if
you go back to the teasers we see the
slasher character is not mr. jingles he
does wield a knife but has a long strand
of hair that's a big disconnect I hope
the show will address assuming that
teasers are connected to the season
that's it for this breakdown video make
sure to subscribe to my channel with the
Belon as I'll be doing episode 2 episode
rundowns and Theory videos just like I
did last season give the video a like
let me know what you think about the new
season and feel free to follow me on
twitter at the story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much